we're going to do in this video is get
some practice doing division with
numbers that are multiples of 10 100
1000 things like that so let's say we
wanted to compute what 2400
divided by
30 is
pause this video and see if you can
calculate it using whatever strategy
makes sense to you
all right so let's think about this
together and i'm going to show you how
my brain likes to handle this we'll do
this out on my little digital blackboard
but eventually you'll be able to do
things like this in your head
so
2400 or 2400
divided by 30 that is the same thing as
four hundred
two thousand
over
thirty
so this is just another way of saying
two thousand four hundred divided by
thirty now the reason why i wrote it
this way
is because
you can now write
each of these the numerator and the
denominators as the product of some
number and either 10 or 100 or a
thousand
so 2400
that's the same thing as 24 times 100
times 100 and i knew that i was like
okay i've got these two zeros at the end
so you could view this literally as 24
hundreds
and then 30 you can view as we got one
zero here so it's three tens the three
is in the tens place
so three
times ten
now what's valuable about thinking of it
this way
is you can
separately divide the 24 by the three
and then the hundred by the ten
so this is the same thing as
let me do this this way
as that times that and so we have 24
divided by 3
24 divided by 3
times
100 divided by 10.
now 24 divided by 3 you might already
know that is going to be eight three
times eight is twenty-four so this is
going to be loosening this is going to
be equal to eight
and what's a hundred divided by ten
well a hundred divided by ten is just
going to be 10.
so our our
quotient i guess you could say is going
to be 8 times 10 or it's going to be
equal to
it's going to be equal to
80.
and we're done
and you might notice something
interesting here
so if i take
my 24
and divide it by
my
and divide it by my 3 i'm going to get
this 8
and then if i take
two zeros and if i take away another
zero i'm going to be left with one zero
right over here so you get 80. but why
did that thing with the zeros work
because you're really taking 24 hundreds
divided by three tens
so 100 divided by 10 well you're gonna
lose a zero that's going to be equal to
10 which has only one zero let's do
another example just to hit the point
home and try to do this next example the
way we just did it maybe in your head or
maybe on a piece of paper so let's say
we wanted to calculate
3500 which you could also think of as
3500 and we want to divide that
we want to divide that by
let me write the division symbol a
little bit nicer than that
we want to divide that
by 700
pause this video and see if you can
compute that
so as we just did we could view this as
over 700 3500 we can view as
times
over
this is going to be over
let me get the right color here
over
times
now the 100s cancel out and we're just
left with 35
over 7. now what's 35 divided by 7 well
that is going to be equal to 5.
and notice you could just say 35 divided
by 7 is 5 and if you're saying how many
zeros do i have left over well i have
two zeros here but since i'm dividing by
something with two zeros those two zeros
are going to be cancelled out now i
don't want you to just memorize that the
reason why that happens is because as
those two zeros here represent hundreds
35 hundreds these two zeros represent
hundreds so if you divide 100 by
hundreds they're all going to cancel out
so you had two zeros before but you're
dividing by something with the two zeros
so you don't have any zeros after the
five year let me do one more example
just to really hit that point home but i
want you to appreciate that it's not
just some magical trick it just makes
sense out of things that you might
already know
so if someone and i'm gonna give this
i'm gonna give a crazy one let's say
we had
million
42 million
divided by
let's say
60 000.
what is that going to be pause the video
and see if you can think about it on
your own
well using the the the notions that we
just talked about you could say all
right
divided by 6 is going to be seven
and then if i let's see over here i have
six zeros so we're talking about
millions and i'm going to draw divide by
four
zeros right over here which is ten
thousands so if you had six zeros but
then you divide by or if you have
millions with six zeros and you divide
by ten thousands with four zeros
six minus four is going to be two so
your answer is going to have two zeros
in it so this is going to be equal to
700. now once again not a magical trick
the way that we got this is that this is
equal to
times a million
we got our six zeros right over there
divided by
six ten thousands
six times
ten
thousand
so our 42 divided by six
that's where we get the seven from and
now
if we one way to think about it if we
divide the numerator and denominator by
10 we lose a zero then we do it again we
lose zeros we do it again we lose zeros
we do it again we lose zeros and so this
thing just all becomes one or another
way to think about it we if we divide
the numerator and the denominator by ten
thousand
this becomes one this thing loses four
zeros
and you're left with 42 divided by six
is seven
hundreds because we have a one now in
the denominator hundred divided by one
so seven hundred